foreign
Linda is with us in Roanoke Virginia hi
Linda welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you for having me sure what's up
okay so I am I'm currently 64 years old
so is my husband
um
I make about 115 my husband makes about
45 and we still owe 180 on our house and
he is not on board with paying the house
off
thank you
he evidently he just does not want to
pay the house off and I've kind of tried
to put my foot down and say you know
when we retire we're not going to have a
house payment
because we're going to have to sell it
and downsize well he's definitely not on
board with that and
I don't really know how to get him on
board and I did listen to one of your
podcasts and um where the conversation
was about somebody not being on board
and I think felony said this is not a
finance problem this is a marriage
problem and I think that's probably a
lot closer than anything
I'm sorry how long have y'all been
married
29 years how much have you gotten your
uh retirement accounts
my retirement is about
my 401 is probably about
[Music]
I have a thousand dollar in my emergency
fund I have two rental properties and
I'm in the process of paying off I just
paid off two of our cars what are the
rental properties worth
um together about two hundred thousand
and what's your homework but
my homework right now it's worth 180.
and you owe 180
yes we owe 180 and it's worth 180.
well no we we oh we owe on 180 it's
probably worth about
400. okay that's what that makes more
sense okay yeah and does your does your
husband have any money in Investments at
all
no and he doesn't he doesn't participate
in any of my rental properties either
yeah you know you got a pretty
significant challenge going on in your
marriage
yes
even the language that you're using my
rental properties his stuff doesn't do
anything
um yeah y'all got yourselves a uh
a mess
why won't you and how long has he not
participated
um have you all been living Separate
Lives
well we have we we put money we have
separate accounts and we have a house
account our health account goes for all
of the things that we use groceries all
the bills and then we have a savings
account that we put money into to go for
anything major like fixes and and water
heaters or whatever we need to put put
that's exactly that's exactly the
situation I had set up with Buddy and
Craig my two College roommates
that's not that's not a wife or a
husband such that's not a marriage
that's a couple of dudes who are uh
that's a couple of roommates
this is probably true how long has this
been going on 29 years
29 years
yeah
and I bought the right when I bought the
first round of property he did not want
any part of it I sell real estate on the
side also besides being a nurse
and so he didn't want any part of that
one and so I've just been running it
I've almost I only owe 12 000 on it so
I'm getting ready to pay it off next
and then I bought another property my
daughter-in-law who had cancer was it
living in a horrible situation so I went
ahead
and bought a house for her to live in
um which is right near me so I could
kind of help take care of her
and that property is probably I owe
about 62 on that one and I'm hoping to
get that paid because I'm snowballing
everything
wow
um I'm not sure exactly what to tell you
Linda
this is so painful
um
hey you guys are so disconnected it's
almost as if
um your little brother who had a mental
disability was living with you and you
go and do everything in spite of him
um with a you know because he's not he's
not on board with rental property I did
it anyway he's not on board with taking
care of the kid that had cancer but I
did it anyway and he's not on board with
this but I did anyway he's not on board
with saving money but I did it anyway
and and I'm the only one has any assets
but I did it anyway and he makes a
fourth of what you make and he did it
anyway
and
and yet you gotta split the mustard in
the refrigerator
I don't I just I don't know what to do
with this except tell you beg you guys
to but guess what this is not gonna work
because I mean you know tell you to go
see a marriage counselor but guess what
he he's not on board he's not gonna do
that what is he on board with and what
what is it he what does he like he likes
his comfy job and he likes just living
the way he lives
um what does that mean
well I mean he goes to work he comes
home he goes to play golf whenever he
gets a chance
that's pretty much it
here's oh man this is gonna be an Umpire
it's going to get me out of trouble with
the internets and that's fine here's
what you have to decide
am I going to it's been this way for 30
years
and this is going to be this way for
another 30 years
and I'm gonna keep plugging along and
doing my thing
and I'm gonna I'm gonna head on down the
road because this is the life that I
walked into or
I'm gonna cause a Ruckus in my living
room
turn on the lights and I'm gonna say
this ends today I hope you will come
with me I'm going to a marriage
counselor right
and as a part of going to a marriage
counselor I'm going to learn that I have
value and partnership and I can't do all
this by myself and I'm I can't keep
dragging you and I can't you can't keep
using me as your bank and you can't keep
using me as your sugar mama I need a
husband I don't need another child
and that might mean that I'm out
that might mean um whatever but I think
you have to make that decision for
yourself and if you decide this is the
life I got it's annoying but it is what
it is make peace with it move on down
the road now
in which case you're probably selling
your two rental properties to pay off
your home
because if he won't sign the deed you
can't sell that home
and you have 180 000 and you don't have
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars to
pay it off
uh you have 175 and 401k and I guess
he's going to retire and eat out of your
retirement
because he doesn't have any retirement
and you do and uh I guess the how that
rental properties that you're going to
sell to pay off your Presidents
um if you make if you attempt to make
peace with it it's going to continue to
have
um poor results in your finances
um because you're going to have to work
around him again and in order to do that
can't sell the house so I've got to pay
it off and can't pay it off with your
retirement because you don't have any
have enough so those I guess those
rental properties are going to be sold
you're going to pay it off if you stay
in this but I
I wish I had found you um 28 years ago I
would have had you I would have
um highly encourage you to go to a
marriage counselor and deal with this I
don't think you're going to do that now
because I think if you were going to do
that you would have done it a long time
ago
I don't feel like I can help her I feel
like she's so far in that she's probably
gonna stay in that suit right uh but but
what I would tell you is this if you're
listening and and John you can throw in
you know whatever you whether you agree
or not or and so forth but
um
we have a we have an inordinate number
of people in their 20s listening to the
show and watching this YouTube and
watching us on television and so forth
um
if you are considering entering into a
marriage a lifelong commitment with
someone
and you don't first make sure that
you're in agreement and going to commit
to stay and adjust in an agreement on
the subject of money
in-laws because there's crazy and one of
your families or both your family
kids how many to have how to treat them
or the inmates going to run the Asylum
or what and
um religion these are the four things
that the data tells us if you're in
agreement on these four things before
you're married you have an inordinate
probability I mean like 90 percentile
probability of staying married happily
through your life
but people that are not in agreement on
religion and lost kids and money
live desperate weird toxic lives and are
ineffective at all four of those areas
they're ineffective in their spiritual
walk they're ineffective with their
money and wealth building their
ineffective parents and they're even
ineffective family members to their
extended family because they're not in
agreement
I'm gonna I'm gonna help my mama even if
you don't want me to you know they're
not in agreement
and and you live your life in angst
because you don't have alignment on
these basic things please for God's sake
don't call it love to marry someone that
you are not aligned with like that
it's not love
it's drugs it's alcohol it's something
it's permanent roommate lust but you're
gonna you're gonna end up with a
roommate that you don't like
I think that I think beneath those four
things is
equally important because I'm thinking
about this like on all four issues my
wife and I were aligned and we are
different on a number probably three of
the four maybe four of the four this 21
years later I think
being in alignment out the gate and
equally important being aligned with
what hap how are we going to act what's
our process for when we get crossed
because you will get cross I want to
help Mom I don't want to help your mom
all right now the alignment is do you
just do what you're going to do how do
we yeah how do we lay how do we set this
problem in front of us and we tackle it
together and you got to have a plan to
go forward in that last call
I don't want you I don't want you
retiring I don't want to downsize I
don't want to do this I don't do this I
just want to play golf
and you make three times what I make so
I'm just going to take the money and
we're gonna put all in the same pot
man that's a dude that's cashed out
right that's a guy that there was no
alignment not only on issues but on how
do we actually solve problems when they
pop up in our marriage and they pop up
in every marriage yeah if you're
listening to the show and you're 24 and
you're dating and you don't take a clue
from how miserable that lady is
there that's what we want you to do
that's why we're coming back to this is
we go you know you have got to make this
a priority it's not a business
transaction it's a values transaction
because if when you can agree on your
money you've agreed on your dreams
you've agreed on your fears you've
agreed on your life
and when you can't agree on your money
you're not agreeing on the basics of
life and you won't sleep and you will
not ever have peace not by yourself not
with your friends not with anybody it
haunts you it haunts you it increases
the likelihood of addictions it
increases the likelihood of sexual
dysfunction in the marriage and
increases all of this okay so these
things are so intricately tied together
that you guys have got to be grown-ups
quit you know this is not a this is not
a Hallmark movie doofus and about your
life on my show people call in and
they're so nervous if I say what I need
out loud he might leave and my response
is always well good
you deserve more than that and I know
you're going to be lonely and I know
it's scary and I know it's frustrating
and uh there's a great comedian he said
the worst part about breaking up
long-term relationships is
um there's no there's no equity roll
over you can't tell your your new your
uh it's Michael Che you can't tell your
your new girlfriend hey I went to her
wedding uh her sister's wedding I ain't
going to this one like I get to carry
that up you don't get to care you gotta
start over again I get that it's all
it's terrible and
the alternative is you spend the next 30
Years
looking at your bank account so scared
to death you can't breathe and you look
over there and there's this lump on us
on a couch getting his golf shoes on
yeah
for God's sakes if you if you you know
if if if you look up and you're
completely misaligned you're going to
you know you you're not going to end up
liking them
they're not gonna end up liking you at
the end of the story so you gotta resent
them you might as well just call it now
yeah I mean early
and before you end up in marriage before
you you know so please folks and and for
those of you that got young marriages
you know you've been married two or
three years and you're struggling to get
to get aligned on these things go sit
down with a marriage counselor
you know it forgot it for God's sakes if
you want to lose weight and and you know
become fit you would hire a personal
trainer so why can't you hire a marriage
trainer or if your breath smells bad you
go to the dentist a professional you
know why so why can't you hire a
marriage trainer you know go you know or
maybe a good start for that has come to
the marriage and money weekend that
we're doing with John deloney and Rachel
Cruz that's coming up
um in October in October I'm looking
around here trying to figure out the
date but yeah
um
yeah that's 19-21 yeah thank you I'm
trying to grab the cheat sheet so I'll
get my act together here but yeah okay
19-21 here in Nashville it'll be at the
Ramsey uh Event Center I don't even
think about that but you could come do
that weekend that weekend's gonna be
pretty intense I think ultimately in
fact I was doing a podcast earlier today
could somebody do that weekend as a
pre-marriage thing you could you could
and here's why because you're going to
be surrounded by people who've been
married for 25 years and for 15 years
and so you're going to get to see some
couples down the road and I think when
people catch them at the break and have
a cup of coffee yeah that's right or you
can listen to the but the challenge
their content's not inappropriate for a
free message I don't know if you said I
do come on in okay or you're about to
that's right but I but I think the at
the end of the day
avoidance cannot be a strategy it can
avoidance when you're dating avoidance
I'm just not going to look at my budget
well the thing I always think about Les
Perry when he says in Dr Lester says you
know when you have these uh strong
feelings about something and you bury
them they have a high rate of
Resurrection they will show up they'll
pop back out and they come back out in
the most inopportune ways the most
inopportune moments uh and and it takes
another five years of therapy to figure
out why they're coming out sideways and
while you're yelling at your kid when
actually it's it's a decision back over
here whatever the thing is but yeah
absolutely yeah so please folks please
do not move forward in these
relationships if you're sitting there in
your three year in a three-year marriage
um you know
how cause a ruckus I'm not going to tell
you what John says I I do not I'm not
going to tell you to go with the
possibility of uh make peace with it
don't make peace with it you've been
there for three years Raise Hell
getting a marriage counselor's office
Raise Hell about it we're going to get
on the same page or I'm going to call
everybody's going to be miserable and
I'm going to be the cause until we get
on the same page I am this is not okay
I'm not gonna live like this the worm
has turned cause a Ruckus get in there
and do the work and figure this out and
find your voice and you know you you can
be as loud or whatever you don't need to
be loud but I mean you can be as bold or
raw as you want to be but cause a Ruckus
it's worth it because it's the only
method to get to healing and let me make
this statement to my fellow gentlemen
out there you can cheat on your wife
with a golf club
and you can commit infidelity with your
job
and so this idea that well I'm I'm all
good I'm following the rules I don't
participate I don't do nothing that's
cheating that is cashing out
yeah you're leaving your wife even
though you're sleeping in the same time
it's a manhood crisis the worst
Suffocation of America you're acting
like a little boy instead of a man throw
your shoulders back and serve your
family
you self-centered twerp this is the
Ramsay show